[Musique]
julian assange a commis ce qui est le
pire dépêchés pour l' empire il a prouvé
que ce dernier était une entreprise
criminelle il a documenté ses mensonges
sont impitoyables mépris pour la vie
humaine sa corruption effrénée et ses
innombrables crimes de guerre
républicains ou démocrates conservateurs
ou travaillistes comme ou baden ça n'a
pas d'importance ceux qui supervisent
lempire ont tous la même partition
satanique
les empires tue toujours ce qui leur
infligent de sérieuses et profondes
blessures
qu'assange dont la santé physique et
psychologique est précaire et qui a subi
un avc le 27 octobre pendant une
procédure judiciaire soit condamné à
mort ne devrait pas surprendre voilà dix
ans qu'il est détenu s'étend dans
l'ambassade d'équateur à londres et
presque trois ans dans la prison de
haute sécurité de belmarsh où il doit
faire face à l'absence de lumière
naturelle et d'exercice ainsi qu'un
incessantes menaces pressions à
l'anxiété au stress ses yeux étaient
désynchronisée sa paupière droite ne se
fermait pas sa mémoire était brouillée
c'est ce qui a expliqué sa fiancée
stella maurice en parlant de son avc sa
progressive détérioration physique et
psychologique l'a amené à avoir des
hallucinations à la dépression il prend
des antidépresseurs et des médicaments
antipsychotiques
il a été observé marchant dans sa
cellule avant de s'effondrer
se donnant un coup au visage et se
frappant la tête contre le mur il a
passé des semaines dans l'aide médicale
de la prison de belmarsh les autorités
pénitentiaires ont trouvé une moitié de
lames de rasoir sous ses chaussettes il
a à plusieurs reprises appelé une ligne
de prévention du suicide géré par les
samaritains car ils pensent mettre fin à
ses jours des centaines de fois par jour
les bourreaux n'ont pas encore achevé
leur sordide travail
toussaint louverture qui mena le
mouvement d'indépendance d'haïti la
seule révolte d'esclaves qui ait réussi
dans l'histoire de l'humanité a été
physiquement anéanti de la même manière
enfermé par les français dans une
cellule exil et non chauffés et qu'on a
laissé mourir d'épuisement malnutrition
apoplexie pneumonie et sans doute
tuberculose et à moins qu'on se mobilise
pour empêcher cette exécution judiciaire
ce sera aussi le destin de julian
assange me rejoindre pour discuter de
l'exécution au ralenti de julian assange
son père john shipton
jaune avant de commencer je voudrais
mentionner le très bon livre de nils
melzer concernant le procès de julian
assange et où il décrit avec des détails
abominable toutes les anormalités légal
qui ont été utilisés en plus du sa page
de réputation tout ce qui a été fait
contre votre fils depuis 2010 et la
publication des irakiens warlogs
à la fin du livre mais l'air est écrit
quelque chose que je voudrais que vous
commentiez
aussi longtemps qu assange restera
l'isolément en prison ni les états unis
ni le royaume-uni ne se presseront de
faire aboutir la procédure d'extradition
plus il est possible de faire durer
chaque procédure légale plus la
stabilité la santé d'assange se
détérioreront et plus l'effet dissuasif
sur les journalistes et les lanceurs
d'alert sera fort
comme les autorités le savent
parfaitement il ne reste plus beaucoup
de temps avant que la résistance
d'assange ne cède s'il devait mourir en
prison ou si sa santé mentale devaient
se détériorer au point de le voir être
dépossédé de ses capacité légale est
enfermé dans un institut psychiatrique
pour le reste de sa vie l' affaire
pourrait être close sans peur d'un
précédent judiciaire ou le 4 janvier
2021 serait classé par un panel de juges
consciencieux de haute cour britannique
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme ou en fin de compte pas la cour
suprême des etats unis
je voudrais que vous en parliez
je vais dans le même sens que niels
melzer comme vous je suppose je pense
que c'est le vrai but de la longue
détention d'assange et je voulais savoir
si vous pouviez commenter cela
bonjour crise merci de me recevoir
cela rappelle le discours d'un rôle
painter
quand il a reçu son prix nobel
il avait dit c'est arrivé mais ça n'est
pas arrivé
concernant julian il a toujours été
considéré pas par moi mais néanmoins que
le royaume uni est un proxy des
intentions américaines
ce qui en réalité est faux
la torture est le fruit des institutions
le service des poursuites judiciaires de
la couronne
le bureau des affaires étrangères et le
pouvoir judiciaire
ce sont ces gens qui font cela ce sont
ces gens qui vont au travail signe un
document qui est un nouvel instrument de
torture visant julian assange puis
rentre à la maison boire un verre de vin
c'est affligeant
si je peux développer un peu
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres
la corruption
la profonde criminalité des états unis
et de leurs alliés de l'otan
et un miroir de cela
un horrible miroir
c'est le traitement infligé à julian
assange depuis 13 ans
qui reflète exactement
il n'y a pas de différence qualitative
la différence n'est que quantitative
sous ce que wikileaks julian assange et
chelsea manning ont dénoncé
ce traitement qui a été démontrée et
vérifier dans le livre de nils melzer
ce traitement que l'on constate avec le
déclin progressif de julian assange
et l'intensité croissante de la
diffamation diffusées par les bouches
les plus violentes
la haine la plus vicieuse
les plus malhonnêtes calomnies
mensonges qui ont entouré julian comme
une tornade ses 13 dernières années
bien cela fait partie du processus
d'isolement parce qu'on parle vraiment
ici d'isolement le cours des événements
est devenu particulièrement dur dans
l'ambassade d'équateur à la fin avec
l'élection de lenin moreno qui suivait
la partition de washington qui a révoqué
la citoyenneté équatorienne de julian
son droit à l'asile
x dans les semaines qui ont précédé et
vous étiez peut-être dans l'ambassade à
ce moment-là il y à une campagne pour
essentiellement essayer de le faire
sortir est l'un des détails que je ne
connaissais pas avant de lire le livre
de nils melzer c'est qu'ils lui ont même
retiré son kit de rasage
quand il est sorti de force il est barbu
il semble débraillé et tout cela a été
fait intentionnellement
en plus de toutes ces accusations qui
s'avère être fausse les excréments sur
les murs et caetera
et ensuite à belle marche il est
totalement isolé
donc il est isolé personnellement si on
parle des conditions d'incarcération
mais ce sa page de réputation qui a
commencé quasiment immédiatement après
la publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
oui je pense vous savez que tout
simplement et des gens écrivent ces
procédures
ainsi sera landen kahn
qui a organisé ces procédures a écrit
une autobiographie qui inclut un
chapitre dans lequel il se vante de la
manière avec laquelle il a organisé la
torture de julian assange
il se vante de son succès dans sa
manière de corrompre les gens
et les conventions d'asile
il se vante réellement d'avoir violé la
loi
et ensuite il se rend au magasin de
souvenirs de buckingham palace
s'est littéralement incroyable
il va au magasin de souvenirs de
buckingham palace
achète une jolie assiette et s'envole
pour l'équateur afin de la donner au
président moreno comme cadeaux en
remerciement du royaume uni et de soeurs
alan duncan lui même
ces gens
c'est une telle insulte faite au
président équatorien
mais ce dernier n'y voit évidemment même
pas une insulte
express une telle arrogance dans
l'expression de leur victoire sur
quelqu'un qui n'a pas les moyens de se
défendre et qui n'a fait que publier ce
que tous les autres ont publié
le new york times le washington post the
der spiegel rigaux
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
des gens sans importance qui g sur des
cadavres pour prendre de l'importance
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
au long et bien non pas vraiment je
dirais déçu oui mais pas surpris
eux ces vingt dernières années
le royaume uni a montré des signes
d'anxiété camp à son unité
et cette anxiété se remarque dans les
restrictions imposées
à ce qu'on peut publier
et les actions contre les mouvements
indépendantistes
comme par exemple la récente
incarcération de craig murray
donc je ne suis pas du tout surpris
qu'il souhaite détruire toutes opinions
dissidentes ou clamant la vérité face
aux récits qu'il cherche à développer te
v
aucunement surpris
mais que le gouvernement australien et
la justice britannique
n'arrive pas à trouver le moyen
d'arrêter de se déshonorer cela me
choque
si je peux poursuivre mon illustration
il ya une centaine de parlementaires
brésiliens qui soutiennent julian
assange
en grèce sur
390 soutiennent julian assange
en france 40 députés soutiennent julian
et c'est la même chose en espagne la
même chose en italie
en norvège neuf parlementaires
soutiennent julian assange
même à stockholm en suède il y en a deux
je peux continuer en australie il y en a
30 en nouvelle-zélande au royaume-uni
donc ce déshonneur qui est le traitement
de julian et compris partout dans le
monde et la seule manière qu'ont ces
gens de sortir de cette situation et d'y
remédier
autrement ils seront déshonoré pour
l'éternité à cause de ce traitement aux
deux d'un simple élégant et talentueux
éditeurs de jeux
très bien après cette pause nous
poursuivrons notre conversation
concernant l'exécution ralenti de julian
assange avec son père john shipton
[Musique]
nous continuons notre conversation
concernant l'exécution aura l'entier de
julian assange avec son père jon shipton
dans la mesure où vous pouvez en parler
est-ce que vous pouvez décrire comment
la pression a commencé à se faire sentir
sur julian ce que vous avez vu
et je dois dire qu'en tant que père je
me dis qu'il doit être terrible d'avoir
à gérer ce sentiment d'impuissance
de voir son fils être soumis à quelque
chose comme ça et de ne pas être capable
d'intervenir en tant que père
en ce sens si vous voulez la colère est
une énergie
et la malveillance la plus sauvage des
malveillances sens et un déluge me met
en colère et donc me donne de l'énergie
pour continuer
et en tant que parent vous savez vous ne
regardez pas ce que ça coûte
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
je ne peux vraiment
le détail de l'incessant
et croissants en intensité recours aux
calomnies
et mensonges malhonnête par les juges ce
que
je vais vous donner un exemple
durant une audience julian et ses
avocats ont demandé si julian pouvait
s'asseoir en dehors du box en verre qui
est au fond du tribunal
et qui est destiné aux terroristes
ils ont demandé si julian
pouvait s'asseoir avec ses avocats et le
juge a répondu non donc les cirques
instances font que julian doit être à
genoux dans ce box en verre est murmuré
à travers une fente
alors que l'avocate de l'autre côté doit
être sur la pointe des pieds coller son
oreille sur la fente pour obtenir des
instructions ou donner des informations
à julian puis cet ajout diane de coller
son oreille
je veux dire ce délire se poursuit
pendant trois semaines
et personne ne songe à y mettre fin
il pense qu'il est normal de traiter les
gens ainsi
c'est épouvantable
absolument épouvantable
vient s'ajouter à cette montagne de
comportement et ne le fait que la
magistrate barid soeur
après les audiences quelques mois après
les audiences
se voit promu
quel honneur
pourquoi cette promotion elle se
retrouve promu pour avoir traité des
gens de la manière la plus épouvantable
je suis plus que choqué je ne trouve
plus les mots
et bien après la condamnation de bradley
manning devenu chelsea manning ce juge a
aussi immédiatement été promus ils font
le sale boulot de l'état pour ce qui est
de la colère saint-augustin a dit
l'espoir a deux filles de toute beauté
la colère le courage colère face à la
situation courage d'envisager qu'elle ne
restera pas ainsi la colère étant bien
sûr quelque chose de très différent de
l'aisne parlons un peu dans la mesure où
vous le pouvez de ce que c'est torture
au ralenti cette exécution ralenti
appelez ça comme vous voulez a fait à
julian
haut
vous savez il met un peu pénible
et inconfortable de revenir sur les
changements progressifs dans la
physionomie et la psychologie de julian
dean
et 5 mai pour parler en termes généraux
il s'est détérioré physiquement
il est très difficile de se maintenir en
bonne santé en prison
c'est vraiment difficile
quand vous faites face à un déluge
incessant de modifications fourbe de la
procédure par le service des poursuites
judiciaires de la couronne
sans intention de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une procédure régulière du printemps
10 ans en public que julian
bénéficierait d'une procédure régulière
donc toutes ces choses induisent une
abrasives érosion de la substance
cette citation quoi la citation que vous
avez prononcé
s'applique aussi à jouer à douze joueurs
et la colère vous pousse à avoir du
courage et à vous battre
ce qui donne du courage aussi c'est le
soutien que julian reçoit l'échelle
mondiale de la part de gens ordinaires
et cela c'est leur à dos
ses l'himalaya qui nous soutient
que des gens ordinaires voit cela et
agissent pour nous soutenir ils font des
donations ils participent à des
rassemblements
il y en allemagne 29 villes où se
tiennent des veillées tous les quinze
jours
depuis deux ans les gens se rassemblent
à sydney une fois par semaine ils se
sont rassemblés une fois par semaine
pendant deux ans à barcelone ils se sont
rassemblés une fois par semaine à
bruxelles je peux continuer encore et
encore à londres il y à des
manifestations toutes les semaines à
piccadilly
ce phénomène ce traitement de julian
la désagrégation de l'image de la
justice
du service des poursuites judiciaires de
la couronne du gouvernement australien
n'est pas passé inaperçu de par le monde
d'ailleurs de terre l'autre jour j'étais
à paris
et je suis tombé sur l'ancien président
brésilien lula the rule qui m'a félicité
pris dans ses bras et dit de l'appeler
si j'avais besoin de quoi que ce soit
dilma rousseff pareil
[Musique]
la liste des gens remarquables de par le
monde vous compris qu'ils viennent nous
épauler
nous avons vous et moi il n'y a pas si
longtemps prononcer un discours à new
york
quand rogers water c'était avec nous
un rogers waters totalement dénué
d'hésitation dans sa conviction qu'il
faut cesser de torture et julian
c'était un moment amusant et fort
c'est comme s'il y avait tout un système
solaire
grandes planètes gravitant autour du
soleil que sont les circonstances
la torture le traitement et ne auquel
julian fait face lui et ce système
solaire l'emportera
je voudrais parler des humiliations
vous avez mentionné le box mais il a
aussi été l'objet de fouilles
corporelles dans et hors du tribunal ce
qui est totalement ridicule puisqu'il
était escorté vers et depuis le box et
dans son environnement carcéral à
belmarsh certains mécanismes destinés à
humilier julian sont utilisés en
permanence pouvez vous nous dire quelque
chose là dessus
oui
le meilleur exemple de ce comportement
et ne
sait que julian a été placé dans l'aide
médicale
l'aide médicale est une aile d'isolement
c'est une zone où d'après ce que je sais
il y à un petit nombre de cellules et
ils sont complètement isolés
c'est extrêmement déprimant et ça a duré
un certain nombre de mois
les autres gens se trouvant dans cette
zone dans les d'isolement sont
[Musique]
vous savez ils sont tous devenus fous
où ils n'ont pas de jambes ou pas de
bras dans un cas
dans un autre un homme est en train de
mourir du cancer écrit toute la nuit
comme été afin de sortir julian de l'
isolement
les prisonniers ont fait une pétition
une pétition pour qu'il soit déplacé
dans l' aile de la prison
dédié aux détenus de plus de 50 ans
la pétition n'a pas marché alors les
prisonniers ont soumis une nouvelle
pétition
qui a encore échoué alors les
prisonniers ont soumis une troisième
pétition pour l'en sortir et ça a marché
voilà les circonstances
les hommes en prison se montrent plus
responsables et plus humain que ceux qui
sont en vérité chargée de rendre des
services décent aux prisonniers
c'est bouleversant
ces petits géôliers qu'ils arrivent au
travail en réfléchissant à une autre
méthode pour se distancer de la réalité
de leurs responsabilités vis-à-vis
d'êtres humains
puis qu'ils rentrent chez eux et boivent
un verre de vin c'est quelque chose qui
doit être réformé immédiatement et dur
des petits heckmann ces prisonniers qui
ont fait une pétition pour julian je
sais que étant donné que quand julian a
quitté l'aide médicale ils l'ont remis à
l'isolément et les prisonniers ont fait
une pétition pour qu'il soit déplacé
dans la population générale
ils comprennent comme vous et moi et des
millions de personnes sur la planète
qu'il a parlé pour nous
qu'il ne parlait pas pour les puissants
il nous a montré la part sombre de
l'élite dirigeante mondiale et nous
n'avons peut-être pas ce genre de
pouvoir mais il ya une solidarité de ce
type
oui ce que vous soulignez la est
important
nous allons brièvement parlé si nous
pouvons
donc c'est il ya treize ans que ces
publications ont eu lieu partout sur la
planète
c'était principalement les documents sur
la guerre en irak et la guerre en
afghanistan
ces publications met un certain temps à
pénétrer la population la culture de la
compréhension
en dix ans elle y sont entrés et les
gens aux états unis en particulier se
sont inventé une expression celle de
guerre sans fin aux
ce n'est pas une expression qui vient du
sommet
c'est venu de la base alors que ces
révélations entré dans la culture et
engendrer la compréhension que les
guerres prenne fin de
la guerre en irak a pris fin la guerre
en afghanistan a pris fin
et la prison de guantanamo bay qui
participent à l'appeler suppurantes du
département de la justice aux états unis
ne tardera pas à être fermé
voilà les bénéfices
de guerre ont pris fin
et l'un des épisodes les plus sombres de
l'histoire du département de la justice
des états unis touche à sa fin
voilà ce qu'ont donné julian
chelsea et wikileaks au peuple des
etats-unis d'australie et du royaume uni
très bien c'était john shipton le père
du fondateur éditeur de wikileaks julian
assange
[Musique]